alors vous n'avez pas pu rater ça ces
dernières semaines tout le monde en
parle
vous avez vu le titre de la vidéo je ne
parle pas de caroline et safia mais bien
de cette fuite de données dingue
et si j'avais une production vous aurez
eu droit à une série d'image dans tous
les sens de jt du monde entier avec
plein de journalistes qui font dans
maple panama papers les panama peppers
par 91 pause mais comme j'en ai pas et
ben se contentera de l'incroyable effet
que je viens de faire voilà les panneaux
ma peur c'est juste la plus grosse fuite
d'information journalistique de ces
dernières années on parle de 2000 600
gigaoctets de données dans 11,5 millions
de fichiers 2006 en gigaoctets salut si
c'est énorme
et ces données elles sont importantes
puisqu'elles mettent en lumière des
liens obscurs entre le monde de la
finance et les paradis fiscaux
le tout en provenance directe de maussac
fonseca qui venait panaméen spécialiste
de la domiciliation de sociétés offshore
alors je vous expliquais un peu mieux ça
mais à titre de comparaison sur les 5
dernières fuites du même genre 4 faisait
moins de 5 gigas on n'est donc
clairement pas sur des révélations de la
même ampleur et c'est aussi pour ça
qu'on en parle autant et d'ailleurs si
ça ne se fait que maintenant c'est
peut-être parce qu'ils ont une mauvaise
connexion tout simplement le truc fait
quand même
1300 oui transfert facile on le voit
qu'il en soit c'est important c'est
important que ce soit arrivé à nos
oreilles et c'est grâce au travail
acharné de 109 rédaction répartis dans
76 pays
je te laisse imaginer la gueule du
google docs ensemble elles ont révélé le
fonctionnement d'un système créé par et
pour l'opacité de ses bénéficiaires
bénéficiaires allant de parfaits
inconnus à des figures de premier plan
issus d'univers politiques économiques
sportives et culturelles
alors ok je peux comprendre que ça
puisse faire beaucoup d'informations
d'un coup on a été saturé donné par les
médias et on sait pas forcément quoi
retenir
heureusement pour vous vous avez sonné à
la bonne porte petit récap tout d'abord
le panama sur une carte ça se passe ici
fait pas genre que tout le monde le
savait je suis sûr y en a un ou deux qui
savaient pas bref dans ce panama il ya
un cabinet qui s'appelle maussac fonseca
et on va voir comment ils ont organisé
toute cette fraude et je veux reprendre
l'excellent de l'état fort développé par
box alors partons du principe que vous
conservez vos économies dans une belle
tirelire cochon posé sur l'étagère de
votre chambre
votre problème c'est que votre mère elle
n'arrête pas de regarder
dans votre tirelire pour pouvoir
s'assurer de ce qui rentre et ce qui en
sort il va vous n'aimez pas trop ça
parce que si elle sait que vous êtes
pété de thunes
elle va vous demander de participer
auprès de la maison par exemple donc ce
que vous faites c'est que vous gardez
vous tirelire cochon dans votre chambre
mais vous en achetez une seconde que
vous allez entreposés chez votre voisin
parce que votre voisin michel sa mère
elle est cool et regarde pas dans les
tirelires qui se trouve chez elle du
coup ça vous permet de faire rentrer et
sortir de l'argent de votre seconde 6 à
lire sans attirer l'attention de votre
mère mais peut-être que la mère de
michel a fait pas ça parce qu'elle est
cool mais parce qu'elle a proposé à tous
les enfants du quartier de garder en
sécurité leurs seconds tirelire contre
une petite somme d'argent
vous avez compris l'idée c'est comme ça
que fonctionnent les paradis fiscaux
comme le panama ou les îles caïmans et
propose une fiscalité très intéressantes
sont très peu regardants de la
provenance de la destination des sommes
d'argent et offrent de réelles facilité
pour y créer des sociétés sans en
révéler propriétaire et c'est cette
opacité qui intéresse tout le monde peut
écrire un faux nom sur la tirelire
cochon qui la cachait chez la mère de
michel en fait la mère michel ces mots
sac fonseka a traversé 40 bureaux
disséminés dans une douzaine de pays
elle facilite la création de servir un
peu spécial qui sont les sociétés
offshore dans les paradis fiscaux les
sociétés off shore c'est un grosse
coquille vide une sauce de vaisseau
fantôme qui ne réalise aucun business
dans le territoire où elles sont
implantées
mais qui se contente de se déclarer
propriétaire de vos actifs et vous
permettre du coup de bénéficier d'une
meilleure fiscalité
sauf qu'en fait il ya différentes degré
d'opacité doublage des pistes la
création d'une simple sociétés off shore
c'est un peu le happy meal de
l'optimisation fiscale
et ce n'est pas toujours suffisant pour
s'assurer une opacité optimale puisque
vous apparaissez toujours parmi les
membres du conseil d'administration de
l'entreprise
donc si quelqu'un vous cherche vraiment
aller vous retrouve donc du coup mon sac
fonseca et propose un truc encore mieux
son menu best of avec l'attribution de
fonds aux administrateurs qui se
chargeront de toute votre paperasse vos
signatures mais aussi de faux
actionnaires qui apparaîtront à votre
place sur des documents qui pourraient
être compromettant et ensuite pour le
maxi best of avec la sauce crimi de luxe
on vous propose de renforcer l'opacité
en multipliant les sociétés offshore de
deux façons la première façon en mode
boîte nuggets
c'est à dire en divisant vos actifs
entre vos sociétés la seconde façon
poupées russes en les impliquant les
unes dans les autres
histoire que l'unique actionnaire d'une
de vos sociétés soit une autre
c était qu'il soit elle même détenue par
une troisième chacune situées dans un
paradis fiscal différent avec ses
propres règles et atypisme autant vous
dire que la fuite des données a dû
sauver pas mal de nuits blanches du côté
de l'illustration fiscal parce que c'est
tout un système qui a été mise en
lumière par ces révélations
sauf que c'est pas parce que vous montez
une société off shore que vous êtes dans
l'illégalité
en fait certains recours par exemple la
société pour faciliter leur
développement à l'international
utilisant l'opacité de ce système pour
préserver leur stratégie ou camoufler
leur identité réelle jusqu au bon
déroulement de l'opération
un peu comme matthew b il voulait créer
son entreprise et s'installer en asie il
a donc créé une société aux îles vierges
britanniques via la branche de moussac
fonseka à singapour car le fait d'avoir
déjà une société pouvait accélérer son
processus d'installation
alors on a voulu en savoir plus sur
mathieu b du coup on a investigué afin
de savoir quel type de personne c'est
dur et on est tombé sur une interview de
lui dans son club de hand ou à la
question une chose que tu fais avant un
match
il nous répond ferme là c'est donc ça a
l'air d'être un garçon parfaitement
normal et pour cause en fait c'est
complètement légal pour un particulier
de placer de l'argent à l'étranger dans
une société offshore sans le déclarer
mais seulement s'il ya ces trois
critères ne pas être assujetti à l'impôt
sur la fortune ne pas percevoir de
dividendes de cette société ne pas avoir
lui-même de comptes étrangers liés à
cette société donc techniquement c'est
possible mais comme le précise
christophe moreau avocat fiscaliste
créer une société off shore et déclarer
tous les revenus qu on y loge ça n'a
aucun intérêt
l'intérêt de création de telles sociétés
c'est qu'elles effacent le nom de leur
propriétaire réel et leur permettent
donc par exemple d'échapper à l'impôt
d'exonérer leur descendance de droits de
succession de blanchir de l'argent ou de
camoufler des actifs à des créanciers
alors ça a l'air fou comme ça mais ça
peut être les gens qui cachent leur
argent avant le divorce par exemple
donc ça c'est légal et le truc c'est que
créer une société off shore pour ne pas
profiter de l'avantagé offert par
l'opacité
c'est complètement absurde c'est comme
si on achetait un citron du sel de la
tequila on part en soirée et que tu me
dises que t'as pas prévu de faire une
tequila paf
du coup c'est pour ça que if they are le
patron du figaro a fait cette
déclaration
monsieur platini mais monsieur platini
un fond pourquoi il aurait pas un fond
si cet argent est déclarée voulait dire
mélange général on mélange tout c'est
vrai que tout est mélangé 1 il n'a pas
tort là dessus on mélange tout on
tout en pâture il y en a marre de cette
société ou demain on va faire quoi le
listing des gens qui ont le sida
oui c'est quoi le rapport savent
absolument aucun sens d'ailleurs si on a
tellement peu qui s'est excusé sur
twitter je regrette la comparaison entre
les évadés fiscaux et les malades du
sida
cool bien sûr qu'ils vision fiscale et
sida n'ont rien à voir mais je n'aime
pas les listings et la dictature de la
délation
ça ne vous rappelle rien alors non
seulement le mec passe d'une comparaison
avec le sida à une comparaison avec la
choix mais en plus il a horreur de la
délation mais attendait divulguer ce
genre d'informations quand on est le
patron du figaro
c'est juste honteux c'est pour ça qu'une
fuite comme les panama peppers a une
importance capitale
on veut pas compter sur ce genre de
personne pour mettre un coup de pied à
la fourmilière de temps en temps du coup
à force de faire pression sur les
paradis fiscaux scandale après scandale
on peut espérer qu'ils abandonnent les
services de dissimulation que leur
client affectionne tant mais justement
on a parlé un peu mieux du système etc
maintenant parlons de les clients pour
voir qui ça touche alors parmi les noms
révélés par l'épargnant peppers on
retrouve douze chefs d'état ou de
gouvernement dont 6 encore en hectares
dont 5 ha on vient de m'annoncer que le
premier ministre islandais a démissionné
en même temps à 7% de la population de
l'islande qui a manifesté pour qu'ils se
barrent les mecs étaient hyper motivés
les gaz y allait avec des bananes et
balancer des petits suisses
vraiment il ya aussi 20,9 des 500 plus
grandes fortunes du monde et 128
dirigeants politiques et hauts
fonctionnaires
évidemment la kazakhe balkany qui sont
basses et des enfants pour le coup quoi
ils sont toujours là on les attend enfin
j'ai pas surprenez-nous [ __ ] enfin
fait quelque chose quoi alors on serait
tenté de dire foutu super-riches
toujours les mêmes les politiques ses 20
ans tous des pourris n'est pas si vite
mon coco sur les 1000 noms de
ressortissants français retrouvé dans
les documents 95% sont des citoyens
lambda aux profils et aux motivations
bien plus diverse que l'on pourrait
imaginer alors c'est des chefs
d'entreprise avec une forte prédominance
des secteurs de commerce de gros et de
textiles des avocats des médecins mais
aussi des commerçants comme des bouchers
ou des coiffeurs un pensez-y la
prochaine fois que vous irez vous couper
les cheveux ça peut être n'importe qui
alors qu'ils ça pénalise cette histoire
eh ben ça pénalise l'état vu que c'est
des gens qui ne paient pas d'impôts sur
ce qu'ils devraient
donc la question qui se pose c'est
qu'est ce que l'état fait contre ça et
bien le problème c'est que françois
hollande qui s'est démontré assez
offensif vis-à-vis de l'évasion fiscale
il a des résultats qui restent
contrastées certes les moyens de lutte
contre la délinquance fiscale ont
augmenté suite à l affaire cahuzac avec
un accroissement des effectifs de lutte
contre les fraudes fiscales ou des
réseaux de blanchiment et l'adoption
d'un texte de loi permettant le
durcissement de la législation mais la
promesse de campagne d'interdire aux
banques la possibilité d'exercer dans
les paradis fiscaux elle a été
rapidement remplacé dans une loi votée
en 2013 par un devoir de transparence
des banques
quant à leurs activités dans les
territoires dits non coopératifs un
devoir de transparence qui montre
clairement son insuffisance justement
dans le cas des panamas peppers puisque
le panama avait été sorti par nicolas
sarkozy de la liste noire des paradis
fiscaux en 2011
et parce que la définition même de
paradis fiscal est en relativement
restreinte
il est assez facile pour les banques de
prétexter n'y avoir aucune activité
c'est le cas la société générale par
exemple et ce tweet de kerviel étaient
juste magique
je souhaite une bien belle semaine à la
société générale ainsi qu'à ses conseils
ht avec panama peppers hashtag panneaux
mannix effectivement elle avait fermé
ses implantations au panama sans pour
autant stopper les relations
commerciales avec mon accent ces cas qui
lui aura permis d'ouvrir un millier de
sociétés offshore pour ses clients la
solution serait donc peut-être celle de
l'échangé automatique des données entre
différents pays promis par hollande en
2013 même si la mesure est complexe elle
sera indispensable pour qui veut
supprimer l'opacité toujours présente
dans les structures offshore et
accentuer la lutte contre la fraude
fiscale
et franchement c'est largement
réalisable en fin 2015 c'était 74 pays
qui avait confirmé par écrit leur
volonté de procéder à ces échanges
d'informations dont le panama et les
accords doivent rentrer en vigueur en
2018 ce qui aurait pu être suffisant
pour nettoyer ce qui va nettoyer donc
les volontés elle semble évoluer dans le
bon sens et c'est une bonne chose
la france elle a par exemple récupérer 2
6 milliards en 2015 grâce à la
régularisation des dossiers de personnes
détenant un compte bancaire non déclarés
à l'étranger
c'est énorme et aujourd'hui ils sont
submergés de demandes de régularisation
parce que l affaire a fait peur à tout
le monde et c'est cool
enfin c'est cool les volontés évolué
dans le bon sens oui et non c'est ce que
j'aurais aimé vous dire
mais depuis vendredi 15 avril et le vote
de la directive secrets d'affaires
c'est un peu plus difficile vous
expliquer un peu les choses le parlement
européen a voté un texte qui est un peu
comme le secret d'état mais pour les
entreprises l'idée c'est de les protéger
de la concurrence déloyale et ce genre
de trucs sauf que c'est un texte qui
peut rapidement dissuader les
journalistes d'investigation où les
lanceurs d'alerté de faire leur taf
s'il ne souhaite pas crouler sous les
procès et on n'est pas sûr que la sphère
des panamas peppers auraient pu être
divulguées dans ces conditions cela va
demander donc encore plus de cran
qu'avant et c'est problématique
mais quoi qu'il en soit c'était
important qu'on en parle aujourd'hui
parce qu'il faut se rendre compte que
l'évasion fiscale c'est le problème
numéro un du financement de nos
économies
alors où de nombreux pays l'union
européenne se serre la ceinture
l'évasion fiscale ça pourrait
représenter mille milliards de pertes
fiscales par an rien qu'en france où
l'évasion fiscale
ça représenterait 60 à 80 milliards de
pertes ce qui est très éloignée des
pauvres 2 à 4 milliards perdus à cause
de fraudes aux prestations sociales dont
on entend pourtant parlé bien plus et si
vous avez du mal à figurer ce qu'un
chiffre pareil pour représenter
l'excellent time to sign of l'a calculé
pour vous
si en france tout le monde joue le jeu
de l'impôt des particuliers aux sociétés
eh ben on pourrait équilibrer les
finances publiques est distribué aux
ménages 80 % des sommes versées au titre
de l'impôt sur le revenu en 2015 donc
allez-y fait du business
enrichissez-vous créer de la valeur
faites lui avons fait du profit mais
juste un truc respecter la loi c'est
tout j'espère que cet épisode vous aura
plu pouce en l'air si c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner pour ne pas
rater les prochains épisodes d'ailleurs
balance bientôt un coup de fil 1 parce
que je n'ai pas arrêté et coups de fil
c'est juste que je voulais tester un
autre truc
un gros merci aux types heures pour
soutenir le projet si vous aussi vous
voulez blanchir votre argent n'hésitez
pas à cliquer sur le lien tipi n'hésitez
pas à me suivre aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux et partager la vidéo si vous
pensez qu'elle est intéressante
love peace